des moissons à l'ancienne à la selle sur
morin en seine et marne une fête se
dérouler ce week-end pour reconstituer
ses moissons ou les chevaux très joué un
rôle essentiel des chevaux que quelques
passionnés s'attache aujourd'hui à faire
redécouvrir portrait loïc braibant
pascal dervieux il était une fois un
adorable patelin perdu en seine-et-marne
la selle sur morin il était d'une
deuxième fois la troisième édition de la
fête des battages la moisson à
l'ancienne
il était enfin andré huet 52 ans breton
de souche et paysans de coeur mais que
se passe-t-il ici donc monsieur
l'animateur simplement la troisième fête
des battages de la selle sur morin la
fête des battages c'est le retour en
arrière le bon temps jadis où on battait
le blé ou utiliser les chevaux c'est ça
c'est la troisième fête des battages
séquence présentation à la ja quenelle
après il ya péter et là j'ai jugé qui
est de mon côté faire le labourage le
canadien après et après on passera
l'accrocheuse lieu il y aura la garde
lui aussi mais malheureusement j'ai
précis at-on droit si on veut on peut
présenter on voulait présentera ce qu'on
fait avec mes yeux bon ben il y aura
d'autres actions beaucoup de la traction
dans le sujet
rappelez-vous première moisson vous même
ah oui moi je m'en rappelle que
j'attache et légères d'ailleurs j'en ai
attaché quelques-unes pour faire voir
aux gens quand même qu'on attachait les
gerbes à la main c'est pour ça que j'en
ai fait quelques 8000 bonne heure le
matin pour les attaquer parce qu'il ya
tellement heureux qui comme dédé avec
une belle moisson de demain est un autre
jour et après demain monsieur lebreton
de seine-et-marne
on attend peut-être parce que si je peux
oui demande que ça de le faire encore
dans 20 ans je suis raide souhaite
d'ailleurs tout coeur surtout avec les
batinses ce serait serré à bord et les
bottes